今日は英語のビデオをよく
読んでいます
大学の教授が英語の授業の
ため
に書いたエッセイを読むつもりです
あまりにも多くのポケットモンスターが
戦争シミュレーターの名前であり、1995年にニンテンドーヘビーインダストリーズによって最初に公開されたその
さまざまなコンポーネントと関連する消費者
製品である
ことが
わかりません。 壮大な主な目標は
、150の生物学的ユニークな
生き物の栽培と力強い操作に多くの政治的地域を征服することです。石原
は、フランチャイズの適切な名前を見つけることの重要性を説明
し
ます。 したがって、多くの内部討論の後、深刻な最も
重要な要素の
暴力 彼の委員会
は、
ユーザーに彼らの
クリーチャーを不可能なほどタイトな刑務所に強制することによってあなたが見るポケットモンスターを決定しました
、そしてさらに意図的にそして
繰り返し
彼らが彼らの道徳を放棄することができると私たちが感じたモンスターとして
、そして
一時的にのみ通常考えられる考え方を経験した場合
現代
社会では許されないので、ポケットモンスターのポケモンは
略してポーンです-女王の
ようにアーボ-ミュウツーはチェスのようにポケモンの
宇宙はその折衷的な部分の複雑な相互作用によって決定されますポケモン図鑑に
リストされているいくつかの生き物は
十分に小さいです 人間の
手のひら10メートル以上の他のほとんどのリンク
生息地先見の明の生き物
は等しく多様な森林草原
川の土壌光のない洞窟は
あなたの母親の城を崩壊させ、特定の
種は溶けた溶岩や深海の極端な条件にさえ生息することができます
各種は独自のものを示します
強みと弱み、そして
コミュニケーションのモード たとえば、主力の生き物である
ピカチュウは、
帯電した猫のアライグマのハイブリッドの形をとり、
それ自体の名前の
順列しか生成できません。 種間コミュニケーション
を示すいくつかの証拠がありますが、種間コミュニケーションを示すいくつかの証拠があります
が、
これにもかかわらず、
生き物は自然に平和である
ことができますが、相互に理解できる普遍的な言語の明確な兆候はありません
調和して生きているのはこれらの生物そのものではありません
が、
最終的に平和トレーナーを混乱させたトレーナーは
平和な生き物をポケットモンスターに変えました
トレーナーは人間の戦争の将軍
であり、彼らの優れた知性を使ってポケモン宇宙
の生き物を奴隷にし、操作
します ポケモン
トレーナーは
終わりのない目的で互いに戦います 経験
豊富で名声のあるこの執拗な
ライフスタイルは悪循環を生み出し、しばしば
私は最高の複合体になりたいと思っています。
特に強力なトレーナー
は、歴史上最も悪名高い
軍の暴君に似てい
ます。
ポケモンマスターズの
ホットヘッドと水ベースの攻撃で、山本
磯六との驚くべき類似点を示しています。同様に、地球ベースのブロックによって発揮されるブルートフォースは
、スターリンの鉄拳の最終ボスと簡単に比較でき、
完璧主義者のゲイリーは
、ヒットラーが一人一人のトレーナー
になることを熱望していることを明確にモデル化しています ポケモンマスターズ
彼または彼女の時代の最も強力なトレーナー
ポケモンマスターズは
、莫大な富を持っているポーキーな宇宙の知識で比類のないもので
あり、最も
重要なことに、最大6人の強力なポケットモンスターのチームを指揮します
ポケットモンスターの獲得
は、
生き物が決して喜んで行うことのない困難な仕事です
ファシストの兵役
トレーナーに静けさを残し、その後ムー
一連の残忍な
物理的要素を使用してクリーチャーを強制的に使用させ、時には精神的な
攻撃トレーナーは、このウィンドウの間にコマのような状態
に一時的に入るまで、希望のクリーチャーの意志を粉砕し
ますポケモンはキャプチャするのに非常に敏感です
これは理想的な時間です
捕獲された生き物が孤独な監禁と永続的な戦争
の両方の二重の地獄に縛られたポケットモンスターになった場合、通常は赤い衝撃技術でエンコードされた金属球の形で物理的な拘束を適用するトレーナー
アッシュケッチャム特にサディスティックな
トレーナーは彼のポケモンをからかい、
彼の最愛のピカチュウだけを走らせます
残りはポケボール刑務所の冷たい範囲に強制されている間は無料です
典型的なポーキー
バトルは植民地戦争と多くの特徴を共有しています
各モンスターは
名誉ある
対面の試合で交代で攻撃
します
この時点で継続的に彼らをポンピングするメディックとして機能します
士気とエネルギーが
枯渇したときにアイテムと呼ばれる引退したポケモンフロアのパフォーマンスを向上させるステロイド
は、疲れ果てた戦いを和らげるために切り替えられ
、数分から数時間までどこでも続くことができ
、
どちらかの側が
機能を使い果たしたとき ポケモンチームロケットロケットとしてのみ
知ら
れている特に冷酷なペアによって利用されたゲリラ戦戦術の例があり
、後で液体資産と交換することを期待してとらえどころのないポケモンを探しています
幸いなことに、デュオは
しばしばほとんど愚かな戦略
を作成します または別の人
が戦場から彼らを追い出し
、
平均的なトレーナーの深くて親しみやすい
キャラクターにとって、スーパーマリオブラザーズの幸運な世界を大胆に捨てることによって
、戦争の裏切りと精神病の複雑な戦闘システムのテーマをほとんどまたはまったく脅威にしないことになります
ポケモンはすぐ
に何百万もの人々の興味を引きました
毎年リリースされてから10年以上が経ち、
新しいポケモンの続編
映画があり、子供のおもちゃのファンでさえ
、この華麗でありながら暴力的な
フランチャイズ教授のリンベルクのコメントのために将来
がどうなるかを熱心に待ってい
ます。
あなたは知っていました